est-ce que vous allez retravailler avec
nos doctes c'est tout simplement un
projet que j'ai fait comme ça c'était
sympa alors on va faire une interview
noda
[Musique]
alors guen est ce que vous avez déjà eu
des doutes sur la qualité des chansons
de votre album est ce que vous avez déjà
eu des doutes sur votre capacité à faire
une carrière solo alors encore une fois
je crois pas que ce soit vraiment un
album en solo c'est juste un projet
alors je dirais oui j'ai déjà eu des
doutes
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des doutes
sur votre talent c'est gênant sur ces
questions non attendez ça c'est les
moins gênante que je pose en fait écrire
des chansons
c'est ma passion et lorsque j'ai
découvert que je pouvais le faire bien
je me suis découverte
j'en suis dépendante et j'adore faire ça
vous avez déjà eu des doutes sur la
fidélité de de votre mac
non non vous savez où il est là twilight
va pas tarder à venir vous voir si vous
continuez à l'effort il est fort il est
en bas des escaliers là il est prêt à
venir est très à venir avec ses bandes
guttman on ne vient pas là
j'ai vu
j'ai
et où sont hébergés comment alors il a
peur que j'ai il dit qu'il a peur que je
lui casse la gueule mais non est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu des doutes sur la
présence d'armes de destruction massive
en irak
question sérieuse j'écris des chansons
je viens de californie j'ai commandé à
côté d'autres disent nana alors mon avis
sur la question
moi j'écris des chansons est ce que vous
avez eu des doutes sur la réélection de
george bush savait j'ai voté et je ne
fais pas la fête là d'accord on a
compris vous avez déjà eu des doutes sur
l'existence de dieu un non non vous y
croyez billy va céder movie
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des doutes
sur l'existence des extraterrestres
haïti non je prends ni thi ha ha ha
c'est une vraie californienne alors elle
croit qu'il a vraiment existé
vous avez déjà eu des doutes sur la
propreté des français attention s'il
avait la semaine dernière
est ce que les chefs de doutes sur
l'intérêt d'être célèbre je crois que
c'est super avec le succès ce qu'est la
liberté et je ne serai jamais ici avec
vous en france je ne voyagerai pas
autant si je n'étais pas aussi célèbre
et c'est ce que j'aime j'aime la liberté
parce que ça permet de créer et je suis
infiniment reconnaissante à toutes ces
personnes qui m'ont permis d'être abattu
je ne changea pas merci et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de linda hardy tube
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu